okay today I'm going to talk to you
about Newton's second law so this is
just a law that Isaac Newton used to
show the relationship between force mass
and acceleration it's summed up nicely
by force equals mass times acceleration
we could also see it if we use this
equation triangle so mass equals force
divided by acceleration we've seen
already that force equals mass times
acceleration and finally to find
acceleration we need to do force divided
by mass so remember force is measured in
Newtons mass is measured in kilograms
and acceleration is measured in meters
per second squared so that's all very
well and good but how does it relate to
real life so I'm going to use examples
of designing a Formula One car now I
apologize in advance to my awful skills
but here we go there's a my Formula One
car right there lovely stuff right okay
there's like let's say okay so let's
imagine this Formula One car has a mass
of a thousand kilograms and let's say
its engine allows it to have an enormous
amount of force of ten thousand Newtons
so let's see how would we find the
acceleration so to find acceleration we
cover it up and it would be force
divided by mass so a force is 10,000
divided by my mass which is 1,000 so my
acceleration of this particular vehicle
would be 10 meters per second squared so
there's car 1 now let's imagine a
slightly different design for the second
one so let's imagine that we've got a
slightly lighter vehicle this time it's
it's got a lower mass so instead of a
mass of a thousand kilograms it's only
800 so it's quite nice and light weight
slightly different design okay
now let's imagine that we still have the
same force from the engine so have the
same kind of energy
but we have overall a different mass so
again let's find the acceleration of
this one to see how mass effects of
acceleration so again we have 10,000 but
this time we're going to divide it by
800 instead of dividing it by a thousand
because this one has got a different
mass than this one here so I just
quickly use my calculator obviously I'll
have a scientific one but I'm just using
my phones it shows up nicely on the
video so 10,000 divided by 800 the
acceleration would be 12 point 5 meters
per second squared so we could see the
lights are it is the lower the mass the
greater the acceleration so this is why
Formula one cars we want them to be
quite light weight we want them to have
a low mass so they have a fast
acceleration so this one so far would be
our winner
okay now let's have a look at a third
alternative a third Formula One car
again drawn very badly so here we go
this might be the worst drawn one yet
wonderful stuff so let's say this for
one car apologies for the drawing let's
say this one is also she asked 800
kilograms rather than a thousand
kilograms but let's imagine this one has
got a stronger engine meaning we'll have
more force applied when we put a foot on
the accelerator so let's say instead of
10,000 Newton's this one has 12,000
Newton's because it has a stronger
engine so let's have a look now again to
find acceleration we do force divided by
mass so again we're going to do 12,000
divided by 8 this time 12,000 divided by
800 because that's the mass of it and
that equals just quickly get the
calculator back up 12,000 divided by 800
equals 15 so that equals 15 meters per
second squared so you could see that is
how these different things are
interrelated the lower the mass the
greater the accelerator
but also the greater the force the
greater the acceleration so a winning
formula from a Formula One car was a car
with a lower mass and a greater force
from the engine so that's basically sums
up Newton's second law and shows how
mass force and acceleration are all
related to each other thank you